good morning it's tuesday two weeks ago
biologists working for the utah
department of natural resources were in
a helicopter surveying the local bighorn
sheep population when they noticed
something
weird it was a three-sided 10-foot high
sculpture installed in the middle of the
desert a location so remote that even
though the sculpture had been there for
years
no one had ever reported seeing it on
social media of course the overwhelming
response was
aliens which would be one very
interesting and two very 2020 and
three very good for sales of an
absolutely remarkable thing which
basically predicted this entire affair
and it really does sound like a parable
i mean scientists are literally counting
sheep the cliche for how to fall asleep
when they are
roused into a dramatic and new kind of
consciousness by an
otherworldly artwork soon afterwards
despite attempts to keep its location
secret people figure out where the
sculpture is and begin to make
pilgrimages leaving all kinds of human
detritus behind from tire tracks to
toilet paper
and the sculpture mysteriously
disappears oh right that's the other
thing the sculpture mysteriously
disappeared
the metal structure has been removed
utah officials said on saturday adding
that they had not taken it down
wait what as dependent clauses go adding
that they had not taken it down is doing
a lot of work but anyway it wasn't
aliens
probably american deserts are actually
home to a lot of artworks that respond
to or
involve stark landscapes like there's
the famous spiral jetty on the shore of
the great salt lake
near marfa texas there's the fake prada
store that has become a popular tourist
destination
and outside of wendover utah you can
find nancy holt's sun tunnels which like
a lot of my favorite art cannot really
be described or photographed effectively
sun tunnels frames the landscape and
shapes sunlight in so many
weird and astonishing ways that at least
when i visited i felt something of what
rudolph otto called the mysterium
tremendous that feeling of awe
and fear and fascination one experiences
when encountering an overwhelming
mystery like it's one thing for art to
be
merely masterful to depict a scene or an
experience so realistically that it's
really impressive
gertrude stein wrote that when people
encounter that kind of art it excites
them
a little but it doesn't really thrill
them and what i'm after is that feeling
of thrill those transitory enchanted
moments when humans experience something
commensurate to their capacity for
wonder to borrow a phrase from the great
gatsby
so who made the utah monolith well
initial speculation focused on john
mccracken who did make very similar
sculptures and whose famous new york
gallerist did say
i believe this is definitely by john but
there's a big problem to that theory
which is that satellite photographs tell
us the obelisk was installed sometime in
and mccracken died in 2011. but whoever
installed the work didn't just like
prop up a three-sided mirror in the
desert they cleared brush around the
site and used a concrete saw to cut into
the stone to serve as a foundation for
the sculpture
this was profoundly intentional for me
though the big question isn't who made
it but
why i find it so interesting and why
other people did too
there's something about the machine-ness
of the obelisk in that landscape that's
fascinating
the contrast between the straight lines
and right angles of human work
and the curves and jagged edges of
earthwork but honestly i don't think the
monolith itself is that extraordinary
what gets me is that it was waiting for
us all that time
and we didn't know about it and then
once we did know about it
it disappeared almost immediately there
are things in life that aren't there
until you notice them and there are
things in life that are there
until you notice them so why did it
disappear maybe the creators of the
monolith were concerned about the legal
and ethical ramifications of creating
art without permission on public land
maybe they just made it for themselves
maybe the little grey aliens got what
they needed
the maybes are essential to what makes
art feel visceral and thrilling to me
and i know it's human nature to seek
answers and i hope we find them but in
the meantime
let's revel in the mystery hank i'll see
you on friday